[Music]
let's go across the big pond and talk to
Sophie in London what's up
Sophie Hi there Dr John thank you so
much for speaking with me of course
thanks for calling in how how you doing
I'm doing great it's freezing here but
the sun is shining so that's great how
about
you it's freezing here and it's pitch
dark so yeah the land of sadness what's
up Sunshine here well I'll try to be
I'll try to be all the sunshine you need
for today so what's up oh awesome thank
you um so uh if it's okay I I'll give a
bit of context first because otherwise
my question makes no sense um so um
essentially uh through my whole working
life um I've been really well known for
working well over my contracted hours um
I've been in my current workplace for
three years um my managers have really
recognized that uh that I work far too
long um and they really really tried to
encourage me to change that um which
I've really resisted um till recently
but I have um since just before
Christmas really tried hard to pull my
hours
back and um I'm suddenly experiencing a
lot of um anxiety um to the point of um
extremely embarrassing uh I'm having
panic attacks at work and um so I'm in
the process of finding a counselor and
um I'm working on my self-care routine
as well but I'm wondering if you had any
other
advice and ultimately I need to S of
communicate all of this to my colleagues
um and my managers um that I'm really
really trying um but yeah I don't really
know what I'm doing I'm so proud of you
what you're talking about is the curse
of the western
world
and it sounds like your body reached a
place it mine reached about it was about
10 years ago when my body said hey I've
been trying to get your attention for so
long I
quit right because if I don't quit yeah
I'm hoping it doesn't quit well it's
it's it's basically like one of your
tires has falling off that's what a
panic attack is that's when your body's
like oh you're not getting this message
so we're just going to start shutting
the system down
right yeah so
um man this would be you would be
somebody who I'd love just to go have a
drink with and sit for a couple hours
because my guess is you got a long story
it's that's pretty it's pretty
remarkable is that
fair um I don't know I talk about work a
lot so I probably bore you to tears okay
so let me let me just cut to it what
does um work is your drug and so my
friend you've heard heard me say this if
you ever listen to the show my friend in
Simpkins he lives right down the street
here uh he
says if busyness is your drug rest will
feel like
stress so you've put your entire
identity into work hours in production
even to the point that now it's you were
that fun kid at the bar who everyone
loved having around because you would
always have one or two drinks too many
and you were hilarious you do the funny
thing you would just go kiss the dude at
the bar like you were the fun friend and
now your friends are like hey dude you
got to slow
down that's your bosses do you realize
what a crazy thing when your boss is
like you got to quit
working no boss says that
right no it's a standing joke so what's
what
is what is work allowing you to hide
from in your
life that's a very good
question that I wish I had a a solid
answer for I don't
really uh I don't really know and and
I'm aware that's something that I
probably need to to kind of I think you
do I think you do I think you don't want
to say
it what is your body trying to protect
you from is it going home to an empty
house is it
loneliness are you married do you have
kids uh I have a partner no kids uh
Foster cat um so uh going home to the
Foster
cat um my partner when he when he's home
cuz he works weird
shifts um
yeah here's what here's what working a
lot did for me I didn't know how to be a
husband I didn't know what I was doing
in the first four or five years I was
married I just got a clear message I was
doing it wrong and I didn't know what to
do and I opened up my toolkit to try to
fix quote unquote fix my marriage and
there was just a hammer in there that's
it I mean I didn't know what to
do and but one thing I did know how to
do is go
work and so I took extra jobs and extra
shifts and then I got a pad on the
back initially and then I got some extra
money in my account
initially and then my wife could do some
cooler things and it felt
right yeah I I don't I you're saying
saying that I I you don't um you uh
didn't know how to be uh a husband I I I
don't know how to be a a person who goes
home or a person who stops working um I
I
just so I like to be
occupied yeah but but what is your body
so terrified from did you grow up with
scarcity growing up did you have food
andsecurity growing up
no U food and security um very um very
fortunate very aware of my privilege
okay did did um was achievement the way
that your dad patted you on the head or
your mom or did you come up in a really
safe wonderful
environment of often without meaning to
very high achieving very um well-meaning
parents really do a dance when they're
Straight A's they really do a dance when
um there's more money being
made that's
really interesting because over time and
by the way this isn't moral failure this
gets encoded in your nervous system your
body begins to understand through
biochemical processes that the way to
connection the way to love those that
are most important to me when you're a
kid it's the adults in your
life is achievement
busyness earning money getting grades
getting into the right schools getting
the right
[Music]
marks that's interest I remember
something my dad said to me
that um I got exam results through and
I'd got like 98 out of 100 and his
response was what happened to the other
two oh man we're more similar than you
think Sophie uh my dad and him and I
have laughed about this um I got one B I
think it was my first semester in
college maybe my second semester in
college I got one B I was so ex I was I
was thrilled
right cuz that was kind of a mess
actually my first semester of college I
don't think I did great second semester
I was like dude I this is school and I'm
smarter to this I got to I got to put
some effort into this and I got all A's
and one b and my dad's first response
was huh would have killed you to just
get one
more and I remember that like that
deflated feeling and he wasn't meaning
that at all I think he was completely
kidding but he didn't have the tools to
go hey you've turned this thing around
I'm proud of you he didn't have that his
dad didn't do that and his my dad my
granddad's dad died when he was 10 so he
didn't have that skill set
right but I I learned early on oh you
will
achieve yeah it's interesting even my
parents are like you work ridiculous
hours and you should really like of
course try to leave the
office
so you've heard me talk about anxiety a
lot it's essentially everyone yeah yeah
yeah everyone who cares about you is
watching you
die and there's something inside of you
that is so terrified of being alone with
Sophie that you will do anything even up
and death to avoid dealing with Sophie
or dealing is probably dramatic just
being
with your body has identified Stillness
a cup of tea in the
morning just asking your partner to to
take the morning off and let's just go
for a walk even though it's pitch black
outside your body has put a GPS pin in
that that says danger danger danger
danger we got to stay
working and I'm telling you the only way
through that is to go directly into that
anxiety there's not another path you
can't go around it and self-care routine
kind of things that is just Band-Aids on
top of
it it just is
okay anyone who's like well you should
just have a warm cup of tea and take a
hot bath just walk away from them this
is deeper than that this is encoded in
oh no no no no no no no no no when I
when I say like self-care routine I'm
meaning making sure that I go for a walk
at lunchtime get some fresh air okay but
it's it's way bigger than that which in
itself is which in itself is torturous
it leaving my death but but I'm talking
it's bigger than
that this is you saying
um I will only work eight hours today
and I will put a thing on my computer
that shuts my computer off at the end of
eight
hours and I'm going to feel so
anxious I'm not going to know what to do
with my hands I'm not my body's going to
go and I'm going to head directly into
that feeling not flip the computer back
up work my way around that software
program and then get back to
it my phones will go off at 6 PM period
I will not turn them back on period and
I'm going to feel that sense of
powerlessness I'm GNA own
it and only then can you ask yourself
what do I actually want to do right
now because here's my problem and you
probably EXP experences too I love
working I like
it yeah like I actually like it and you
have to think of it like
alcohol like it's okay to like having a
drink it's okay to like having
two then it will kill
you see what I'm
saying yeah I think so but I don't think
you want to please tell me tell me tell
me I'm so curious cuz I that you know
what are you scared
of I think you know what is
it don't know
who say it it's like I don't know
sorry don't be sorry at all this is hard
stuff
it's like I don't know who I'm going
home to
yeah is your partner
safe mostly yeah that means no that's a
really bad that's a really bad answer no
it's not it's an ohuh no you can't walk
it back now you already said like it's a
truthful answer it's not a bad answer
you can't be mostly safe because that
means you're not
safe and now it makes perfect sense to
me while your body has said you will go
to work and you will stay at work you
will keep working and then you will keep
working on top of that
and your bosses are like oh my gosh so
if you go home and your parents are like
honey go
home and your body's saying we
can't are you going to love Sophie
enough to go
safe sorry I'm trying to order the words
in my head and no don't don't just speak
just
speak
[Applause]
I don't think I realized till you asked
the question I know it's
scary I want you
to do something you probably haven't
done in a long
time and instead of fighting your
body fighting that need to go work
finding that need to not be in your home
I want you to flip the whole
script put your hand in your chest and
ask yourself this question what if my
body's
right what if the safest place for me on
planet Earth is at a work environment
where God what amazing bosses you have
they're even caring about you outside of
here they care about your mental and
physical health and wellbeing there's
not a lot of bosses on planet Earth that
act like that
that's very true that is very true you
still have Mom and Dad that ah man they
probably man if if if if they could do
it over of course they would change some
things but they still care about their
baby
girl and then you go home to a
dragon you know if he's goingon to be as
sleeping dragon or if there's GNA be
everything's going to be on
fire so here's the deal I'm not going to
put you on the spot cuz I know this is
hard and if you've never thought about
this before it can be really
overwhelming inside your body I'm going
to ask please please call somebody today
and go get in and go see
somebody and in your situation I don't
really care what the cost is because
you're not safe
physically okay
fair
okay but I'm going to tell you it sounds
to me like your body's working perfectly
and in a strange way than God it's
chosen
work as the Avenue of safety over some
sort of substance over some sort
of um thrill seeking
behavior and I'm going to say this too I
don't know that your colleagues at work
need to know the insights of all of
what's going on in your life maybe
they're safe enough and you can tell
them but if you're an abusive situation
you've got to go find a place for your
body to be safe and you if you ever
listen to The Show for more than two
episodes you know I don't ever tell
people to end a relationship get out I'm
telling you get
out if he's not safe get
out it's the only way your body's
goingon to let
you
breathe
we love you Sophie we're here anytime
you want to call reach out
anytime any resources we got for you
whether it's Financial uh support or
whether it is uh through the The Total
Money Makeover stuff and financial peace
or it's any of the books anything we can
do to help you let me know we got
you I think it's time to ask
yourself where can I go and be safe
God I know this is
hard but you deserve to be
safe